what five things does a screenplay have
to have for you to be interested in it
as a producer five things yeah what five
things I never thought about breaking it
down to five things you know I think you
know first and foremost for me is the
script just has to be you know in my
eyes put well written so it's got to be
a like I think a story that and I don't
care what the story is in terms of genre
or you know people ask me like you care
you know you care about certain genre
and there you seem to work in all
different genres I said yeah because I
mean to me good story transcends onra it
has nothing to do with genre genre is
just sort of a set of conventions that
allow people to identify what kind of
movie it is and therefore whether they
want to see it or not but genre has
nothing to do with web you could tell
good story in any genre and to me
working in different genres part of the
excitement of working in this business
like why so many of us love being in
this business right we don't go to the
same office necessary every day and we
can we're always pursuing something
different and so that the having
different genres to work in is is great
so to me it's just a well told story
like is there some sort of character
some sort of protagonist kind identify
with his your journey in some way I'm
gonna use the word likeable I'm just
gonna say is it like a protagonist I can
identify with in some way I want to
follow him for some reason you know is
that does he have goals does he have
flaws is there an antagonist that's
creating conflict with this guy and you
know a girl whatever the situation is
but is there there something I can get
behind and you know is there a is there
a strong theme like why are you telling
this story so I mean you know I think
just in terms of just being well-written
and then I would say number two is then
what's you know the budget range and
there's a budget range that's reasonable
so a lot of people they come to me and I
get a lot of how much would it cost to
do this script and I'm like well I'll
tell you what I'll answer that question
if you can answer a question for me how
long is a piece of string that's what I
like to ask them you can't just give me
a script how much does it cost to make
that was Matt Damon in your movie right
well your budget went up by ten million
dollars I mean I can make an argument to
do this movie for a million bucks or ten
million bucks
so really it's more like how much can
you raise and then you know or or how
much do you have or you know if they if
they really don't have a good idea of
this who do you see in it how why
you see being distributed but I have to
get an idea of sort of what range and
how big they're seeing this in their
head and a lot of times I might read the
know a lot of times but sometimes I
might read this Creek and get well
that's not gonna that's not gonna happen
on this you know you're not gonna do
avatar on a $500,000 budget or whatever
so it has to be doable you know for the
for the for the budget you know the end
and beyond that to just I guess
logistically feasible so you know for me
to do I mean I you know sometimes I look
and I go yeah I mean you know the budget
the budgets okay it's possible but I
think for some other logistical reason
it would be very challenging to pull
this off even if it's you know budget
wise it can be done you know there might
be something else I might see that that
would make it that would preclude it
from being you know oral actually
actually at least allowing me to do it
effectively for whatever that reason is
but I think those are really the two
main main things that I look for is just
you know is the budget reasonable for
the for the script and is the script you
know well-written and beyond that and do
I like working with this person do I you
know do I get a good good sense because
you're gonna spend a year or more
dealing with this person depending on
the scope of my duties so you know
sometimes I'm just literally brought on
to there's no development I'm like okay
the scripts decent you know and I think
I can influence it enough through the
production process to make it a good a
good picture and then at post when I
deliver the master drive or the DCP or
whatever the final deliverable is I'm
done I'm not involved in marketing or
distribution there are projects like
that it just depends on the term of the
contract so but I would say at the least
I'm staying at least a year with this
person so so yeah well-written script
reasonable budget and logistics and and
I like the person those are really my
main criteria I don't like if you get to
five I don't yeah I get there could be
like sub there can be sub factors within
there but those are sort of the broad
scope factors
you